[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
les cheats et mondial sur rt france au
sommaire aujourd'hui l'antarctique le
continent le plus froid et le plus sec
au monde mais ici ce sont les enjeux
géopolitiques qui réchauffe les esprits
gare différents états se disputent de
vastes territoires qui n'appartiennent
pour l'instant à personne alors comment
se passe cette confrontation
diplomatique pour l'un des continents
les plus mystérieux au monde
fin octobre la commission pour la
conservation de la faune et de la flore
de l'antarctique échouent à se mettre
d'accord sur la création des nouvelles
aires marines protégées
un projet que ses initiateurs présente
comme un moyen efficace de protéger
l'environnement
la cause de cet échec et le veto apposé
par la russie et la chine qui estime que
cette initiative ne prend pas en compte
leurs positions ce qui génère le plus
des tensions politiques
ce sont les revendications territoriales
sur le continent blanc
elles sont par exemple la source d'une
brouille diplomatique récente entre
l'argentine et le chili
alors que les débats se poursuivent sur
l'appartenance des territoires
antarctique certains états renforcent
leur présence sur le continent
parmi eux la russie et la chine qui
organise des expéditions polaires et
construisent de nouvelles
infrastructures
washington lui entend se rattraper la
construction de nouveaux brise glace est
annoncée en 2020 mais sur fond de
pandémie de coronavirus les autorités
américaines se voit obligé de couper le
financement de leurs programmes polaire
[Musique]
avant de poursuivre voici ce qu'il faut
savoir sur le principal accord
international définissant le statut
juridique de l'antarctique
c'est le blitz le 1er décembre 1959 les
12 états qui ont une présence sur le
continent blanc signe le traité sur
l'antarctique
il entre en vigueur en 1961 depuis
d'autres pays ont adhéré ils sont 54
aujourd'hui le traité vise à faire de
l'antarctique une région consacré à la
paix et à la coopération interdisant sa
militarisation il gèle en effet toutes
les revendications territoriales qui
étaient émises au moment de la signature
du document par c'est cet état qui sont
l'argentine l'australie le chili la
france la norvège la nouvelle zélande et
le royaume uni une étape supplémentaire
a été franchie en 1991 avec l'adoption
du protocole au traité sur l'antarctique
il proclame le continent de réserve
naturelle consacrée à la paix et à la
science est interdit aussi toutes
activités relatives aux ressources
minérales autre que la recherche
scientifique dans le droit international
la tactique est inscrite comme terre de
paix et de sciences pourtant en réalité
cette paix est apparente et ne serait
que la partie visible de l'iceberg
géants que sont les relations
internationales
sous prétexte de la protection de la
nature certains pays proposent la
création de nouvelles zones marines
protégées
elles interdisent tout type de pêche ou
d'extraction
ces pays souhaitent étendre leur
influence dans l'antarctique mais
rencontrent une farouche opposition de
la russie et de la chine qui entendent
bien s'ancrer aussi sur le continent
moscou y mène des recherches poussées
afin d'évaluer des réserves potentielles
de gaz et de pétrole alors que pékin
achève la construction de sa cinquième
station polaire de son côté washington
s'efforce de rattraper ses adversaires
pourtant avec la pandémie le budget pour
l'émission polaire et drastiquement
coupé pareil pour l'australie et le
royaume uni qui affiche depuis de
nombreuses années des ambitions
croissantes sur le continent polaire
alors comment les différents états
promeuvent t-il leur intérêt en
antarctique qui revendique
voix sur ce continent quels sont les
richesses
il se cache dans les seuls de ce
continent glacial pour répondre à ces
questions nous rejoignons tout de suite
frédéric lasserre directeur du conseil
québécois d'études géopolitiques
monsieur lasserre bonjour bonjour tout
d'abord parlons de la proposition de
créer de nouvelles aires marines
protégées en antarctique pensez vous que
la situation écologique dans la région
les rendent vraiment nécessaire alors
c'est évidemment un sujet a des bases
scientifiques mais c'est comme ça que
fonctionne le pensait pour la commission
pour la conservation des ressources
vivantes de l'antarctique qui tous les
rassemble toutes les parties prenantes
du traité de l'antarctique il ya des
scientifiques qui effectivement estime
que à la fois avec les impacts majeurs
du changement climatique on observe dans
les régions polaires et avec la pêche
qui est assez peureux surveillée dans la
région tactique il ya matière à
protection environnementale de création
d'aires marines protégées pour essayer
de protéger l'environnement il est la
foule intacte êtes vous d'accord avec la
position russe selon laquelle certains
et ave le promouvoir leurs propres
intérêts par la création de ces
nouvelles aires je pourrais comprendre
ce point de vue mais pas nécessairement
de la même façon que les partisans de
cette position je m'explique
d'abord si la russie défend lui l'idée
que cette création d'aires marines
protégées défend les intérêts des étapes
c'est le cas aussi pour la russie qui
aimerait bien avoir plus de flexibilité
pour prospecter d'éventuelles ressources
naturelles à exploiter d'une part
d'autre part la création d'aires marines
protégées suppose que tous les états y
compris ceux qui la propose se verront
limités dans leurs possibilités
d'exploiter des ressources naturelles
donc créé des à marine protégée ne
favorise pas les intérêts en matière de
ressources naturelles pour les états
qu'ils proposent c'est simplement je
pense plutôt du côté des relations
publiques ça fait bien paraître les
états qu'ils proposent c'est à marine
protégée dans la mesure où ça va dans
l'air du temps on essaye de protéger
l'environnement en antarctique avec des
arguments scientifiques comme je le
disais qu et puis il ya aussi des
aspects politiques de relations
publiques positif pour les états qui
promeuvent la création de seat césaire
marines protégées de mais je pense
que ça protège leurs ressources
naturelles possibles donc vous pensez
que la course de l'an tactique c'est pas
pour bientôt et ne sera pas lancée je
pense que les dispositions
réglementaires et des et
conventionnelles à travers le traité de
l'antarctique et le protocole de madrid
font en sorte qu' il ya peu de chances
que il ya une course pour
l'appropriation des ressources en
antarctique jeudi peu de chance on ne
sait jamais ça dépend effectivement de
la coopération qui se maintiendrait
ou pas au sujet de la protection
environnementale du continent
antarctique mais dans l'eure dans l'état
actuel des dispositions du traité
je ne crois pas qu'il y aurait une
course à la population des ressources et
des espaces maritimes territoriaux en
attaque
et vous pensez que le chili et
l'argentine qui ont des prétentions sur
de vastes territoires et qui se battent
pour ces deux territoires c'est pas un
exemple justement deux sets de 7 avant
course pour pour la région alors j'ai
pas dis qu'il ya pas de prétention augny
de disputes
il ya effectivement l'exemple du chili
de l'argentine du royaume unique qui ont
des prétentions qu'ils soient qui se
chevauchent en antarctique
il ya un certain nombre d'états qui ont
et formuler des revendications sur le
continent antarctique qu'on appelle le
jargon juridique des états dits
possessionnais mais ils ont tous signé
le traité de l'antarctique de 1957 qui
prévoit précisément le geste de ses
revendications
donc à moins que ces états ne dénonce le
traité de l'antarctique ce qui ne semble
pas être le cas à court terme ils ont
émis des revendications
et puis ces revendications sont sans
effet puisque ils ont accepté de geler
avec moi l'expression de geler leurs
revendications territoriales dans la
région et c'est la même chose pour
l'australie pour leur usine pour la
nouvelle-zélande pour la france qui ont
aussi anglais des revendications sur le
continent antarctique
merci beaucoup monsieur lasserre nous
allons poursuivre notre analyse tout de
suite mais nous retrouverons à la fin de
l'émission pour plus de détails sur la
question merci encore
fin octobre 2020 une vraie bataille
diplomatique se joue entre les membres
de la commission pour la conservation de
la faune et de la flore ma
in de l'antarctique la principale pomme
de discorde et la création de nouvelles
aires marines protégées où toute
activité d'exploration ou de la pêche
serait interdite le premier projet porté
par l'union européenne qui souhaite
créer une aire marine protégée au nord
de l'antarctique
d'une superficie de 1,8 million de
kilomètres carrés la zone couvrirait une
partie de la mer de weddell près de la
péninsule antarctique pour leur part
l'australie la france et l'union
européenne prône la création d'une aire
marine à l'est de la péninsule article
une zone riche en coraux d'eau froide
sur un million de kilomètres carrés
enfin il y à la proposition de
l'argentine et du chili d'une troisième
aire marine protégée au nord-ouest de
l'antarctique là où se concentre la
majeure partie de l'activité économique
sur le continent notamment en pêche et
en tourisme
ces trois projets ne sont pas en
concurrence selon leurs initiateurs
l'objectif de ca mpda ventoux protéger
l'environnement fragile de l'océan
austral les aires maritimes protégées
sont essentiels pour la protection des
écosystèmes uniques et fragile de
l'océan austral et elles maintiennent la
capacité de ces écosystèmes à s'adapter
aux impacts du changement climatique
parmi les 26 membres que compte cette
commission 2 et à déclara leur
opposition totale à ces projets ce sont
la russie et la chine
et si pékin estiment que ce projet est
mal fondés du point de vue scientifique
le chef de la délégation russe y voient
une tentative de promouvoir les intérêts
géopolitiques de certains états une
situation ambiguë s'est développée
certains pays ont une sorte de désir
irréfléchie de fermer d'immenses
étendues d'eau d'autres de ferme est
immense étendue d'eau qui sont
étonnamment adjacente au secteur d'
influence de ces états c'est alarmant
en effet les zones que couvre ces aires
marines protégées coïncide bien avec les
prétentions territoriales de ses
initiateurs par exemple une amp proposé
par l'argentine et le chili se trouve
bien dans la partie nord-ouest du
continent que réclament ces deux états à
la fois le royaume uni qui a oscillé
viser pour cette zone soutient ardemment
cette initiative au sud la mer de ross
est revendiquée par la nouvelle zélande
qui a réussi à convaincre en 2016 les
membres de la commission à soutenir la
création avec les états unis d'une amp
là bas à l'est c'est un peu pareil une
amp proposé par la france et l'australie
se retrouve exactement dans la partie
que ces derniers réclament quant à la
partie nord et les robes indiqué par la
norvège cependant en nombre de stations
scientifiques et appartiennent à l'union
européenne qui défend depuis plusieurs
années l'idée de la création d'une zone
de protection spéciale dans ses eaux
pourtant toutes ses prétentions
territoriales sont gelés par l'accord de
1959 qui proclame l'antarctique une zone
de paix et de coopération
dès lors de nombreux états et renforcent
leur présence via l'installation de
leurs bases scientifiques à ce jour une
trentaine de nations il possède en tout
soixante seize stations dont 40
permanente et 36 saisonnière
le plus grand nombre de bases appartient
à l'argentine et au chili qui sont les
plus proches géographiquement de lan
party la russie compte 10 stations
polaire dont la célèbre station vostok
où la température la plus basse sur la
planète a été enregistré - 89,2 degrés
celsius la chine en a quatre l'orgueil
uni et les etats unis ont trois stations
chacun enfants la france on possède 2
les recherches s'effectuent dans près de
90 domaines scientifiques dont
l'astronomie la géologie et la biologie
bien entendu l'intérêt de tous ces états
ne se limite pas à la science
ce qui attire surtout la convoitise se
situe dans les sols ou plutôt sous la
glace uranium fer cuivre zinc manganèse
cobalt molybdène mm or et argent
ce n'est qu'une partie des ressources
naturelles dont les traces ont été
découvertes par les scientifiques les
hydrocarbures qui serait aussi en
abondance la société gulf oil a estimé à
plus de 50 milliards de barils de
pétrole les réserves qui se trouve sous
la glace des maires de oued el aid
d'auros en outre cette région très
isolée renferme la plus grande réserve
d'eau douce de la planète soit près de
70%
et si les activités de pêche ne sont
toujours pas réglementer l'exploitation
minière ou pétrolière est strictement
interdite par le protocole de madrid et
ce jusqu'en 2048 date à laquelle expire
ce traité international
de nombreux états se préparent déjà à la
conquête du continent blanc et surtout
de ses ressources naturelles
alors quel pays se montrent de plus en
plus actifs dans cette partie du globe
quels sont les principaux points de
discorde entre les signataires du traité
sur l'antarctique
enfin comment ce continent est il était
découvert la réponse après la pause
[Musique]
plus grand et plus froid désert au monde
l'antarctique reste aujourd'hui un
territoire protégé est dédié largement à
la science ce statut lui est conférée
par le traité sur l'antarctique première
tentative réussie de s'entendre sur les
règles du jeu sur ce continent
découvert il ya plus de 200 ans selon
l'interprétation la plus répandue
l'antarctique a été découverte en 1820
lors de l'expédition bus de fabienne
godet vous spelling à houssen émirats
elle lazareff ce fait est contesté par
plusieurs pays notamment le royaume uni
et les etats unis les deux insistent sur
l'antériorité de leurs compatriotes
l'anglais edward bransfield et
l'américain nathaniel palmer la vraie
conquête de la terre australe débute
pourtant à la suite du 6e congrès
international géographique
réunis à londres en 1895
c'est le début d'une période connue
comme l'âge héroïque de l'exploration en
antarctique
quand de nombreuses expéditions en
provenance de différents pays s'achemine
vers les terres polaires à cette époque
les puissances mondiales commencent à
réclamer leur part du gâteau
en 1908 la grande-bretagne proclame que
la terre de g
ainsi que certaines îles antarctique
sont soumises au pouvoir du gouverneur
des îles malouines territoire
britannique d'outre-mer en 1917 le
royaume uni élargi ses revendications
sur un grand secteur dans la partie
ouest du continent
exigeons tous les territoires entre 20
et 80 degrés de longitude ouest jusqu'au
pôle sud
ensuite en 1923 l'état octroie à la
nouvelle zélande sont dominion des
territoires antarctique découvert au 19e
siècle par l'explorateur james ross
la france aussi entre en rivalité même
si ces explorateurs ne sont pas parmi
les premiers à poser le pied en
antarctique le pays en appel à la
découverte de la terre adélie fait en
1840 par le navigateur français dumont
d'urville
cette prétention d'une taille modeste
est stipulé dans un décret de 1924 et
reste la seule revendication
territoriale française jusqu'à présent
le partage du continent se poursuit en
1933 le royaume uni confère à
l'australie son ancienne colonie
un immense fief dans l'est de
l'antarctique la norvège aussi se
montrent actifs dans la région
la patrie de rola monson découvreur du
pôle sud montre ses appétits en 1939 en
revendiquant ses droits sur une vaste
zone au nord du continent
cependant les convoitises norvégienne
chevauchent celle de l'allemagne nazie
dont les ambitions se propage jusqu'aux
terres australes à la veille de la
seconde guerre mondiale l'allemagne
cherche à obtenir une zone dite la
nouvelle souabe le japon à son tour
aspire aussi au statut de puissance en
antarctique ils réclament un territoire
qui correspond en majeure partie à la
terre marie bird le seul territoire
antarctique non revendiquées par un état
aujourd'hui
finalement les accords de potsdam est de
san francisco en terre les ambitions de
ces deux pays
au début des années 40 le chili et
l'argentine revendiquent respectivement
les territoires antarctique et justifier
leurs prétentions par leur proximité
géographique
après la seconde guerre mondiale la
situation autour du continent blanc
devient conflictuel en 1949 des
différends territoriaux provoque un
échange
par des coups de feu entre les chiliens
et les argentins sur la péninsule en
tactique le royaume uni s'implique en
s'adressant à la cour internationale en
1955 pour exprimer son désaccord avec
les prétentions sud-américaine
réclamations qui ne sera pas satisfaite
les états unis et l'union soviétique
aussi s'inquiète du futur statut des
territoires polaire washington essaie
d'élargir son influence et en 1946
organise une opération maritime en
antarctique
intitulé itunes elle a pour objectif
l'exploration de la région ainsi que
l'essai de nouvelles armes et
technologiques tandis que les passions
se déchaînent autour du continent blanc
le gouvernement soviétique adopte le
mémorandum sur l'antarctique qui
rappelle que le continent a été
découvert par les russes et qui assure
que le pays est prêt à y défendre ses
intérêts pour refroidir les ardeurs
autour de l'antarctique 12 pays se
réunissent enfin à washington et signe
le 1er décembre 1959
le traité sur l'antarctique ce document
gèle toutes les revendications
territoriales et affirme que
l'antarctique est une terre commune
consacrée à la science au 21ème siècle
pour les états unis l'inde tactique
n'était pas une destination prioritaire
pourtant avec l'arrivée de donald trump
les choses ont changé son administration
voilà percée russe et chinoise comme une
menace et semble prête à relever le défi
de la compétition l'arctique prédéfinis
en quelque sorte la façon dont
j'envisage de l'antarctique
quand je regarde nos adversaires les
glaces de l'arctique qui fondent et la
compétition de la russie et de la chine
nous devons faire attention cependant
comment dominer la zone polaire sans
pouvoir y naviguer car aujourd'hui les
états unis n'ont que deux brise-glaces 1
affecté au pôle nord et un autre au pôle
sud
un seul d'entre eux est de classe lourde
donc exploitables dans les conditions
les plus extrêmes c'est le polar star
pourtant il a été construit il ya plus
de 40 ans et et multiplie des pannes
enfin c'est yamoussou avec une flotte
redoutable qui compte plus de 40 brise
glace dont 5 à propulsion nucléaire
unique au monde avec en plus quatre
nouveaux brise glace nucléaires en
construction en russie la finlande
elle en possède 7 le canada est la suède
ont si brise glace chacun la chine 1 à 2
dont un flambant neufs mis à l'eau en
2019 pékin projetterait par ailleurs la
construction d'un troisième navire à
propulsion nucléaire
un retard auxquelles il faut remédier
immédiatement estime donald trump qui
ordonne la création de toute une flotte
de brise-glaces d'ici neuf ans nous
avons en ce moment le plus grand brise
glace au monde en cours de construction
nous allons tenter d'avoir si nous le
pouvons d'hybris glace supplémentaires
en effet washington a ordonné en 2019 la
construction d'un nouveau brise-glace
lourde pour 746 milliards de dollars
néanmoins la date de sa mise en
exploitation reste pour le moment
inconnue est la pandémie vient
compliquer encore plus la conquête de
l'antarctique ainsi les etats-unis ont
annoncé des coupes dans le budget en
antarctique pour la saison 2009 1 2021
idem pour l'australie la grande bretagne
la nouvelle zélande l'union européenne
et d'autres pays réduisent leurs
activités au pôle sud au minimum et à
annuler la plupart des nouveaux projets
seul le ravitaillement des stations
existantes et la rotation du personnel
seront pour l'instant assuré entre-temps
moscou et pékin continuent sur leur
lancée en russie l'année 2020 et même
proclamé de l'année de l'antarctique
pour le bicentenaire de la découverte du
continent austral par les marins russes
pour célébrer ces dates moscou organise
deux expéditions qui font le tour du
monde en 2020 l'une est scientifique et
mobilise des navires océanographiques
qui ont visité l'antarctique au passage
pour collecter des données est la
seconde comprend trois voiliers en
honneur aux voyages des marins russes
accompli au 19e siècle
de plus en février la russie mène des
recherches sismiques en antarctique
le but étant d'évaluer des réserves
potentielles du gaz et du pétrole
l'enjeu est de préserver les positions
déjà forte de la russie dans
l'antarctique
la chine elle n'a pas davantage
historique dans la région pourtant ce
retard est le rattrape à pas de géant
la chine est déjà un des plus grands
pêcheurs dans la région et veut encore
accroître sa prise en mars 2020 pékin
contracte la construction du plus grand
navire pêcheurs du krill au monde conçu
spécialement pour l'antarctique
mais ce n'est pas tout en pleine
pandémie sont puissants brise-glace
dragon de neige de multiples idées
expédition vers le pôle sud
l'objectif est la recherche mais aussi
la construction de la nouvelle station
polaire chinoise
cette station sera la cinquième pour la
chine et la troisième dans la zone
revendiquée par l'australie canberra est
un partenaire proche de pékin dans
l'exploration de l'antarctique
et pourtant les experts s'inquiètent de
plus en plus des ambitions chinoises à
long terme de parfois suggéré que la
chine peut chercher à long terme une
revendication territoriale en
antarctique
les activités de la chine en antarctique
contribuer à établir une présence
significative en créant des faits sur le
terrain
un exemple concret pour fonder ses
préoccupations à la station chinoise de
kunlun ouverte en 2009
elle se trouve à un endroit stratégique
au plus haut point au dessus de la mer
en antarctique ce qui en fait un avant
poste crucial pour les satellites
chinois
du coup depuis 2013 pékin propose
d'établir une zone de gouvernance
spéciale autour de cette station sans
succès l'australie se pose surtout à
cette idée qui pourrait réduire l'accès
à la région pour d'autres plus en plus
la zone proposée se trouvent sur le
territoire revendiqué par canberra et
entre temps d'autres acteurs n'attendent
pas c'est le cas par exemple de
l'argentine
en septembre 2020 son congrès approuve
officiellement l'extension du territoire
argentin jusqu'au pôle sud
c'est 1,7 million de kilomètres carrés
de plus en effet en 2016 l'onu a
approuvé une petite extension de zones
économiques exclusives argentine l
argentine va du coup en profite et sauf
qu'elle étend ses appétits bien au delà
des zones octroyé par l'onu en un
tactique la nouvelle frontière argentine
empiète sur la région revendiquée par le
chili du coup celui ci réagit est
déclaré hors la loi
l'extension de l'argentine nous rejetons
cette initiative pour mieux comprendre
l'avenir du continent le plus froid de
la planête nous revenons vers frédéric
lasserre directeur du conseil québécois
d'études géopolitiques
monsieur lasserre qui est aujourd'hui le
champion de la maîtrise de l'antarctique
selon vous alors il ya plusieurs étapes
qui se pose effectivement comme des
champions de la protection de
l'antarctique puisque c'est par ce biais
là que censément les enjeux
géopolitiques sont en tactique se
traduisent donc les états occidentaux
mais aussi la chine ont accepté il a
réussi dès l'époque de l'union
soviétique est encore à l'heure actuelle
en déployé énormément d'efforts de
recherche scientifique en antarctique où
ces états sont signataires du traité de
l'antarctique et du protocole de madrid
donc c'est difficile de dire qui est un
état qui se détachent parmi tous ces
signes faire comme toutes ces parties
consultative donc ce qui est marquant
dans la gestion dans la gouvernance de
l'antarctique
jusqu'à ce jour en tout cas c'est qu'il
ya une réelle coopération politique il
ya des différences il ya des avis
parfois divergents où on l'a souligné
tout à l'heure mais globalement il ya
une réelle coopération politique au
sujet de la protection de de
l'antarctique
qu'est ce qui nous attend après
l'expiration du protocole de madrid at
il beaucoup de chance d'être prolongée
de mai 48 c'est la date de la fin du
délai pour une révision du protocole de
madrid à l'unanimité à ses 2048 ça ne
prévoit pas non plus de l'expiration du
protocole de madrid il va se poursuivre
simplement il peut être modifié à la
majorité des trois quarts des parties
consultative autrement dit ça demeure
extrêmement lourd extrêmement compliqué
de modifier le protocole de madrid donc
un seul et pas par exemple ne le
pourrait pas si la russie et de la chine
par exemple c'est d'aller de l'avant
pour apporter des modifications au
protocole de madrid
il faudrait qu'il recueille
l'assentiment l'accord des trois quarts
des parties consultative du protocole de
madrid donc un coin de passer sous ses
institutions le traité de l'antarctique
et le protocole de madrid vont demeurer
en place après 2048
à moins que une évolution politique qui
fait en sorte que bon nombre d'états
choisissent de dénoncer le traité de
l'antarctique pour nos manches
aucun état ne semble vouloir emprunter
cette avenue mais d'ici à 2040 ce qu'il
peut se passer évidemment beaucoup de
choses
quel sera l'avenir de ce continent à
long terme que sera son rôle finalement
dans la vie de l'humanité
alors évidemment c'est difficile de se
projeter à très long terme
ce que je pense ce que je vois pour
l'avenir de l'antarctique c'est que la
coopération scientifique que j'évoquais
à l'instant ce qui a très bien
fonctionné malgré les différentes malgré
les désaccords politiques occasionnels
elle devrait se poursuivre des états ont
aussi intérêt à poursuite de la
recherche scientifique puisque à des
enjeux scientifiques réel parce que
aussi politiquement assad ça suppose un
certain nombre davantage politique de
maintenir une façade de recherche
scientifique et de coopération saks
comme comme pour les états qui propose
désert marine protégée il ya un avantage
politique indirecte à promouvoir la
coopération scientifique dans l'arctique
et je pense qu'il va y avoir
effectivement encore des disputes des
divergences est-ce qu'on crée des aires
marines protégées ou pas est-ce que les
états dits possessionnais endroits des
plateaux continentaux étendue par
exemple avec le l'australie la norvège
le chili et l'argentine ont promulgué
des et des plateaux continentaux étendu
ce qui paraît un petit peu étonnant dans
la mesure où ils ont accepté de geler
leur pénétration territoriales bref il y
a des divergences politiques je le
disais mais je pense que ces divergences
vont continuer à être gérable on va
réussi à trouver d une modus operandi
des mots des modes de fonctionnement
pour poursuivre la coopération politique
en antarctique
merci beaucoup je rappelle frédéric
lasserre directeur du conseil québécois
à d'études géopolitiques a apporté son
analyse
dans cette émission merci encore
monsieur lasserre cette partie là n'est
pas encore terminée la semaine prochaine
une nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial
alors à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]